little did start off as kind of a who
ordered that moment it didn't fit any
pattern with the solar system but with
the march of technology we eventually
came to find that it was actually the
harbinger of the third zone of our solar
system the third class of planets that
it was the first discovered of a vast
region of fascinating objects intimately
tied to the origin of the solar system
there are many scientific questions that
New Horizons is going to pack in
exploring the Pluto system but one of my
favorites has to do with the origin of
the Pluto share in binary which has
strong analogies to the origin of the
earth-moon system by having a second
example we can both see things that
teach us more about the earth-moon
system but at the same time we have to
deal with complexities like why are
there five satellites in the Plutonian
system maybe more we'll soon find out
versus the Earth Moon that looks pretty
clean as a binary pair created through a
giant impact New Horizons has an odd
combination a fast and slow involved
because the spacecraft is moving fast
and when we're in the heart of the Pluto
system we're only there briefly but then
the playback is slow in part because of
the great distance and in part because
of the large solid state memories that
we fill simply take a long time to
download and so while the drama and the
excitement of the actual data collect
the flyby will be over in a matter of
weeks the playback takes an order of
magnitude longer about 16 months let's
let this little ball represent a Pluto
which is with my finger I'm illustrating
the direction of the pole vector so it's
rotating like that and seen from the
spacecraft approaching from about a
million miles away on the final day and
flashing through the system through the
heart of the satellite system interior
even to the innermost satellite and then
out of the system
and will target to fly through the
occultation shadows of Pluto and its big
moon Charon to look back watch the
sunset and rise through those
atmospheres to study them
spectroscopically embedded in the the
nature of the Pluto system this rich
satellite system is the possibility that
the small satellites have created ejecta
debris that could harm the spacecraft at
this tremendous speed while we're aware
that there could be unknown hazards
because after all this is exploration
from everything that we know we're
sending the spacecraft on the safest
possible course models indicate that we
have something less than a 1 in 10,000
chance of being struck by something
dangerous in large part because we are
flying through the system making a
closest approach where the big satellite
Sharon carves out an evacuated region
that should have much less debris than
anywhere else so we'll be very
interested late in the evening of July
the 14th here the spacecraft check back
in knowing that it successfully made the
passage through the Pluto system through
the danger zone after we fly past the
Pluto system finish the data collect we
hope to go on to explore ancient small
core / belt objects the building blocks
of small planets like Pluto New Horizons
itself is is very likely to be timeless
it's on an escape trajectory from the
solar system will orbit in the galaxy
where there's to our knowledge nothing
that can really hurt it in any finite
period of time in fact even after the
Sun Goes red giant and the earth is
consumed along with the other inner
planets in our solar system spacecraft
like New Horizons will survive as relics
of not only our civilization but our
solar system
you